hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast using networks to
understand the genotype-phenotype
connection presented by our fabulous
keynote presenter dr. John Quackenbush
professor of computational biology and
bioinformatics at Harvard University and
the dana-farber Cancer Institute I'm
Susie bow there is now will be our
moderator for today's educational
webinar presented by Madras the reading
scientific social networking website
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located at the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your questions into the box
that appear on the screen well answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem please join me now in
welcoming our keynote dr. Quackenbush I
will now turn the presentation over to
him welcome sir well thank you for the
kind introduction I hope you didn't
raise expectations too high but it's my
pleasure to be here today at this
virtual conference and what I'm going to
do is I'm going to share with you some
of the work I and my colleagues have
been doing around using networks to
really explore the genotype-phenotype
connection and I decided really to focus
on one area in particular but I'm going
to start by giving you a broader picture
of how we think about building models
and what we do when we create models so
I like quotes and one of my favorite
quotes is a quote you probably see many
times it's from George box he said
essentially all models are wrong
but some models are useful and what I'm
going to do today is I'm going to try
the class of models that we've been
using and the question we ask is not is
the model right but rather what we try
to ask from the models we build is
what's the explanatory power of that
model what does the model show us that
we couldn't know otherwise so I'm going
to start sort of tongue-in-cheek by
telling you how not to do network
analysis and this is really a philosophy
I think a lot of people have adopted but
it's one and I hope I'll explain why but
I don't think is exactly the right way
to do it so in the field we had access
to tremendous quantities of gene
expression data and one of the things
that we've gotten very comfortable with
is taking those data and comparing two
different phenotypes and when we compare
those phenotypes the question we
typically ask is what genes are
differentially expressed and it's a
reasonable question because what we
really want to know is what processes
distinguish these two different
phenotypes but as we look at that
question of differential expression we
also recognize that when genes are
co-expressed they're probably or at
least possibly interacting through some
kind of network mechanism they may be Co
regulated they may represent proteins
that interact with each other somehow in
carrying out processes in the cell and
that's what the cell is expressing them
at the same time and so we assume
there's some kind of interaction and one
common way to explore that is to take
some type of additional data besides the
scheme - besides gene expression data
like protein-protein interaction data
and to merge those together and what
people have often done is taken
protein-protein interaction networks and
done essentially what my colleagues and
I often refer to as node painting you
color the network with differentially
expressed genes and then you ask
questions about how these genes or the
proteins they encode are linked together
and often that involves a process that a
former postdoc of mine stefan benthic
referred to as bio poetry you take the
genes and you tell a story so there's
some potential
with that one of them is should the
things that are differentially expressed
actually be connected if we have genes
that are up in one situation and down in
another vice versa
should they be linked together in the
network and I'm not sure that's actually
true and then the other question is is
that protein protein interaction Network
do we use even relevant if proteins are
not being expressed they're not going to
be linked together and so if we use this
data we may draw some spurious
conclusions and I'm not saying that we
haven't learned things from doing this
kind of analysis but I'd say there must
be a better way so there's another thing
that people do that similar and that we
start with differentially expressed
genes but once we have those what we
tend to do then is to try to build
Network based models and so I'm going to
have to click ahead see if this works so
we're going to do a statistical analysis
and we're going to take our
differentially expressed genes and then
we're going to use those to look for
correlations in the data so we're going
to look for sets of genes that are well
correlated and we'll draw those as a
network and when I draw that kind of
network there are different ways to do
it sometimes they take all the genes
that are correlated sometimes I may
limit myself to correlations between
transcription factors and their targets
but either way to interpret this data
what people often do is to do the same
kind of node painting and the same kind
of storytelling and again I won't say we
haven't learned things from doing this
kind of analysis but it's not really
principled and there are open questions
which I think still have to be addressed
number one are things that are
correlated actually functionally related
correlation doesn't tell the whole story
and number two are the correlations
going to be the same in different
phenotypes and the fact that we look at
differentially expressed genes really
suggests that the correlations are going
to differ between one phenotype and
another the other thing which we often
worry about at least in my group we
analyze this kind of data is if we only
focus on the differentially expressed
gene
don't they work with other genes to try
to create the networks and the
phenotypes that we observe so are we
losing too much like doing this kind of
analysis so we've developed the
philosophy to look at networks slightly
differently so I won't claim it's right
I think it's better in some ways but
here's what we do we'll take our gene
expression data and then we use a very
principled way to try to infer networks
that are specific to individual
phenotypes or we'll take those networks
and we'll build networks that we think
reproduce individual elements of the
regulatory processes that we see active
in those phenotypes we then compare the
networks and fundamentally that's the
key to the analysis we do by comparing
networks we can ask how are they similar
and how are those networks differ from
each other to do that we look at the
topology in the structure of the
networks we compare those to Paulo G's
to find differential patterns and
instead of being individual genes
they're actually differences in the
edges of the interactions in the network
and fundamentally that's what I think we
want to get at and then we try to
combine data in different ways
to learn things from those differential
edges or differences in topology that we
observe so that's going to be our basic
philosophy and I can tell you that over
the last few years my colleagues and I
have developed a whole host of different
methods designed to try to take
advantage of these but our starting
assumptions are that number one there's
no single right network there's no
universal network that's going to
describe everything the second and this
is probably the most important and that
is the structure of the network matters
and that network structure is going to
change between states between phenotypes
and actually the change in that network
structure we believe should be
informative about the underlying biology
so we're moving from that question of is
the model right instead to ask the
question is
the model useful what's the explanatory
power of the model itself so we really
want to dig into this question of
whether or not the network model informs
our understanding of biology so I
mentioned we developed a lot of methods
we published some of these some of them
are still under review one of them is a
method we published last summer summer
of 2016
looking at bipartite community structure
of expression quantitative trait loci
and I'm going to come back to that one
in a little bit a few years before we
published a gene regulatory network
modeling approach we refer to as panda
I'm not going to talk about that today
unless people ask questions but we've
used panda fairly extensively to look at
a wide array of different situations and
compare different phenotypes and ask how
do those regulatory processes change so
we have R in Python implementations of
panda as well as MATLAB implementations
and you're welcome to download those and
work with those we also developed a very
interesting approach to inferring single
sample networks so this is something
which I'm very excited about but again
I'm not going to talk about it in detail
today the idea is actually very simple
we call the method lioness and if I look
at all the people who are listening to
this presentation today if I collect
data from all of you
I could infer a gene regulatory network
for the collective body and then if I
pick one of you and set you aside I
could infer Network for the remaining
individuals and believe it or not when I
do that those two networks are slightly
different and by comparing those two
networks by subtracting their adjacency
matrices but by comparing them I can
actually estimate the network for the
individual I set out and again we've
applied this in a variety of different
situations and circumstances to learn a
lot about what regulatory processes are
correlated with different phenotypes so
we published a number of different
papers describing the applications of
these methods and we're very excited
about the potential if I had two hours
I'd probably tell you more store
raise including a story about another
method we developed called monster then
monster was inspired in a way by my
background and data from my colleagues
in physics where we look at two
different phenotypes and represent them
as two different networks and ask
ourselves if I have a healthy network in
a disease network how does the state of
one transition to be the state of the
other and by looking at a transition
matrix we can actually map one network
to the next so there's a lot of things
that I could talk about but what I'm
going to do is really focus on taking
all of these methods and in particular
one and applying them to what I think is
one of the most interesting datasets
available today for method development
and application and that's the gtex data
set gtex is the genotype tissue
expression project and in gtex what they
did was they collected almost 600
research subjects they're all people of
guy who consented to be part of the
study
they've genotyped all these individuals
they sampled 50 different sites across
the body and they profiled gene
expression in those 50 different sites
so this is really a very rich data set
to begin to look at and to begin to try
to explore and so what we decided to do
was to take the wealth of methods we've
developed and this large data set and to
begin to ask questions about how we
normalize data across all the different
tissues how we model gene regulatory
processes and compare them between
tissues what the differences are between
men and women in terms of expression and
regulatory processes in each tissue but
the last thing I want to tell you about
is or the the main thing to tell you
about is really what I think is one of
the most interesting and exciting
discoveries that we made in looking at
these networks across multiple tissues
and that's an analysis of the role that
snips play in determining phenotype
so I tend to frame this is the problem
of solving the G wasps puzzle so you
know what's the G wasps puzzle well the
way I think of it is that genetic
studies work exquisitely well if we have
highly penetrant Mendelian disorders if
we find genetic variants that have a big
effect size but most of the phenotypes
we look at don't have those large effect
sizes rather what we find are many snips
that have very small effect sizes so
there are two studies that have been
published in recent years that I think
really underscores some of the
challenges and opportunities here
they're both from a big consortium that
refers to itself is giant and this is
the first study a study looking across
multiple jiwa studies to collect gene
expression re to collect genome-wide
variation data so snip data and to link
it to a common phenotype and in this
case the phenotype they looked at was
height so they had about 240,000
individuals and with those 240,000
individuals they looked for associations
between different common genetic
variants in height when they did that
they found about 700 that explained 20%
of height a lot but when you go beyond
20% it gets even worse to get to 21% of
height you need about 2,000 variants to
get to 24% you need almost 4,000 to get
to 29% in almost 10,000 okay that's a
lot of genetic variants to explain
something we all recognize as having a
heritable component so is this unique
well the answer is no they also did
another study where they looked at about
330,000 individuals and asked what are
the genetic variants that are associated
with BMI body mass index and again what
they discovered is sort of surprising it
took almost a hundred snips 97 to
explain 2.7 percent of the variability
we see in BMI and they actually conclude
that all common snips may explain 20% of
body mass index all right so for me
that's sort of surprising
and what it points to is really the
problem we have in trying to understand
rare disease so our complex disease
excuse me so if we want to look at
complex phenotypes like complex diseases
we're going to be looking for in
discovering many many many genetic
variants that have relatively small
effect size now one possible explanation
that's been offered as a way around this
is to look at rare variants but they've
actually been conflicting studies
published recently that either say rare
variants explain none of the
heritability of diabetes or that rare
variants can play a role in explaining
some of that genetic background for
other diseases so I think the jury's
still out on rare variants but even
there the effect sizes are likely to be
rather small and in fact that's what
we've seen so far so how do we solve
this problem we give up on genome-wide
Association studies do we find map
everything and really try to look for
these rare variants that may or may not
be informative or do we think
differently and then the fact that I'm
giving you this presentation means I
think we should probably think
differently so a few years ago we got
funding from the National Heart Lung
Blood Institute to take G Wasat that had
been identified in studies of chronic
obstructive pulmonary disease and we
wanted to map those to function and the
problem we had was that many of the
variants that we looked at I did not
have an obvious functional association
many fell in energetic regions they
weren't tightly linked or associated to
genes it was difficult to think about
how we test them or how we interpret
them so when we thought about this
problem we decided we're going to go
back to the closest thing we could
measure in large scale to phenotype and
that's gene expression so we decided to
endeavor to understand expression
quantitate quantitative trait locus
analysis or eqtl analysis so what's an
eqtl well what we do is we take
genome-wide data on genetic variants we
take snips and we combine that with
genic
rushon data so about 15 years ago a
variety of different groups realized
that they could generalize the
quantitative trait locus analysis that
Steve Tanksley and his colleagues
developed in the 1970s to study the
medically important problem of tomato
breeding but where you can measure
quantitative traits and associate those
traits with the expression levels of the
associate those traits excuse me with
the presence or absence of different
genetic variants so about 15 years ago a
number of groups recognized that each
one of the 25,000 or so genes in the
genome could be tweet treated as a
quantitative trait so we measure their
expression levels we look at the genetic
background in each individual and we do
a regression analysis to ask the
question which snips which genetic
variants are correlated with the degree
of gene expression for each one of the
genes we want to study so this has been
an area where people have worked for
some time and what most people rely on
when they do these studies are what we
refer to as sis acting snips so if I
have a gene sitting right here if I have
a snip located immediately adjacent to
that gene that's what we refer to or
call a sis acting snip and what it means
is that snip is directly adjacent to the
gene so that's one that's easy to study
it's easy to interpret that snip may
disrupt the transcription factor binding
site or some other enhancer site and it
can change the expression level of that
gene I can actually go into the lab
today and use CRISPR to change the
promoter site to introduce that variant
and to test its effect but one of the
other things that a lot of people ignore
are transacting snips those genetic
variants that are far away not located
in the immediate vicinity of a gene but
far away that may actually be associated
with the expression level of this gene
so we decided to do an eqtl analysis and
to keep both the system transacting
genetic variants that we found and then
we decided to do something a little bit
different we took those system
transacting each
yells and we calculated them using the
tool we really love called matrix eqtl
but we took those snips
we took the genes we calculated the
eqtls and our hypothesis was that when
we looked at them we weren't going to
see them sort of randomly associated
across the genome and in networks but
instead if we will give associations we
might see not individual snips and
individual genes but many to many
relationships who would manifest
themselves in the context of an each UTL
network so we thought that they should
group together functionally and that we
should be able to look at that function
and then through guilt by association
begin to associate genetic variance with
functional consequences so we performed
a standard eqtl analysis it's a simple
regression analysis associating the
genotype with gene expression levels and
the trick that we played was we
represented those eqtl associations the
many to many associations between one
snip and many genes or one gene and many
snips as elements and what's referred to
as a bipartite graph so what's a
bipartite graph would simply graph that
has two types of elements in the case of
the the diagram I'm showing you we have
squares and circles or snips and genes
and then a bipartite graph the squares
are only connected to circles the
circles are only connected to squares we
don't have associations between snips
we don't have associations between genes
we only have associations in the model
between a snip and the genes that's
correlated with or the gene and the
snips that it's correlated with so we
represent the data as a bipartite graph
and then we go back to what I started
talking to you about at the beginning of
this presentation we asked a question
what does the structure of this network
tell us about the underlying biology so
we really started to delve into the
network in its structure and like melt
most network scientists the first thing
we did and this was really motivated by
my colleague John platting
is we took a look at the degree
distribution so I probably should have
mentioned we started the study using
data available from a large study of
chronic obstructive pulmonary disease so
we had lung tissue we had gene
expression data from RNA seek we had
genome-wide snip profiles and when we
built this eqtl network what we saw was
that the degree distribution was exactly
what we expect all right
so in network science we talked about
the degree distribution we plot the log
of the frequency versus the log of the
connectivity or the degree and when we
make that log log plot in naturally
evolving networks like the internet
telecommunications networks what we see
is that log log plot of log of frequency
versus log of connectivity has a
straight line distribution people
sometimes refer to it to scale free
distribution it's actually formally a
fat-tailed distribution but if you look
at it what you see for both the genes
and the network and the snips and we
plot them separately because they're
vastly different numbers of genes and
snips but if you look at the genes and
snips what you see in this network is
that both of them had that kind of
straight line distribution so the
networks are at least what we'd expect
now
when we look just at the snip Network we
started to ask the question we set out
to answer what do the genome-wide
Association discovered snips the jiwa
snips in COPD what do they actually what
can we learn from those by looking at
the network so we took this degree
distribution and against it what we did
was we plotted those jiwa steps now when
we started one of the things we focused
on initially was the area down in the
lower left hand corner of the plot it's
what we refer to as it gets the lower
right hand in the corner and the lower
right hand corner of the plot it's what
we refer to as the hubs right these are
the things that are highly connected and
our expectation was that if we
had genetic effects that were big they'd
probably appear in the Hobbs so when we
plotted the variance and hopefully you
can see them here in red when part of
those genetic variants that were disease
associated what we found was that the
hubs are G wasps desert so why is that
well if you look at it they're actually
a couple critical ways or critical areas
you can look at this and a couple
possible explanations my colleague Maude
fagging will tell you that the hubs are
so rare they're unlikely to accumulate
disease associated hits but I still
think maybe they could appear there by
chance and the way I understand this and
an explanation that I like is based on a
story so one of my favorite stories that
illustrates why I think the G Weiss hubs
are deserts of the e GTL hubs or deserts
dates back to world war ii in world war
ii the Royal Air Force the United
Kingdom was flying missions dropping
bombs on Germany and continental Europe
and the planes were coming back shot up
full of holes now the Royal Air Force
did like to see their planes being all
shot up so what they did was they
engaged in a project to map where all of
the bullet holes were and then to design
armor that would protect the planes
where they were getting shot so they
were all geared up and ready to go into
production
when Abraham Wald who was a statistician
walked in took one look at their plans
and said stop you want to put the armor
with a bullet of where the bullet holes
aren't and the answer for why that makes
sense is very simple you see the holes
that don't shoot the plane out of the
sky the holes you don't see are the ones
that bring the plane down in the same
way I think what we're looking at is in
part dictated by survival bias if we
look at the hubs in the network we
actually don't expect to see genetic
variance because if they're deleterious
they're very unlikely to disrupt the
entire network so that whoever carries
those variants doesn't survive long
enough
pass them on the truth is is probably
some combination of the two they're rare
but if they're rare they're going to be
lethal so if we go back to looking at
this distribution now we see one other
interesting thing that thing that we see
is that when we look at the leaves the
things in the upper corner of the
distribution we discovered that the
leaves are actually underrepresented
relative to what we'd expect to see from
the distribution and then in the middle
of the distribution we see there's an
over-representation of jiwa snips so we
started to ask ourselves why those
things in the leaves are most likely
this acting snips associated with a
single gene but you know what about this
stuff in the middle and why do we see
more than we'd expect purely by chance
so to address this question what we
decided to do was to ask whether we
could use some of the properties of the
network to understand what the snips are
doing and to understand why they might
be over-represented
so could we look at the network in its
structure to understand the functional
role of these snips so the idea that Jon
platic I actually developed and applied
was that we should look at the
underlying structure of the network
itself we should look at communities
within the network now what's a
community well you have a mobile phone
and in principle you can call anybody in
the world but in practice you don't
write you have different communities
depending on the day of the week but all
of you probably have a family community
so you call your wife or husband your
husband calls your son or daughter your
daughter calls your son your son calls
his grandmother your mother calls you
you have a family community that's
defined by an increased likelihood that
any two of you will call each other in
any given day relative to the likelihood
that somebody in your network is going
to call a random person say me right so
while you may one day call me the
likelihood that your mother or
grandmother is ever going to call me
is close to zero right so you have a
community that is determined by an
increased likelihood that any two
members in that community are connected
in the same way we decided we could look
at this bipartite representation of each
UT LS this bipartite Network and
identify communities so what we decided
to do is to adapt the method that it had
been developed for looking at bipartite
community are looking for communities in
bipartite graphs and what these methods
all do is optimize something referred to
as the modularity we're looking for
communities that are defined by being
tightly connected to each other more
connected than we'd expect to see by
chance and to our surprise what we
discovered when we looked at these
communities in our copd network was that
we had a number of very tight highly
connected communities what we refer to
as highly modular communities the
network is really organized around these
tight communities now if you look at
this plot what you'll see is we have a
matrix it's really the adjacency matrix
with zeros and ones represented as dark
colors and white and the dark colors
represent edges or connections between
snips which are running vertically and
genes which are running horizontally so
if you look you can see dark stripes
that run up and down particularly to the
right-hand side of this diagram and
those are the global hubs but you also
see these communities are very tight and
really very well localized and isolated
from other communities there are
connections but they're not tightly
connected outside they're very tightly
connected within now what's interesting
is when we start to look at those
communities in the ETTL network and this
is just a different representation I
tend to refer to this as the
Botticelli's Venus representation of the
data
they're like little seashells when we
look at these what we see is there are
52 different communities that we found
those communities are highly modular
they have a modularity of about 0.8 so
they're really tight
and of 34 that are connected together
what we call the giant connected
component 11 of those when we look at
the genes in those communities are
strongly enriched for genes which have
shared function right so the communities
are grouping genes not in a random way
but they're grouping genes in ways but
enriched for particular biological
functions and in fact the enrichment is
significant so what we started to ask
ourselves was if we look at the COPD
associated jiwa snips do these map to
our networks in some way that can
meaningfully tell us about what
functions they might influence so when
we did that what we found was the
majority of those jiwa snips mapped to
communities who were over-represented or
enriched or functions that made sense in
the context of explaining and
understanding the disease so the network
is actually organized around
functionally related communities and
when we look at that Network what we see
is not a single snip regulating a single
gene but in the context of what we might
expect from a complex polygenic trait a
family of genetic variants regulating a
process and in hindsight it should it's
exactly what we should have expected to
see and essentially is what our
intuition told us to look for so one of
the questions people often ask is are
these communities based on their
locations in the genome
this plot actually says no what we
really see is the communities are
drawing both snips and genes from across
the genome so we then started to ask
well if we look at these communities
just like we look at global hubs before
could there be local hubs that tell us
something about the structure of each
individual community and when we looked
we decided we had to define a metric and
this is a metric that John and I refer
to as the core score it's essentially a
measure of how
the modularity in each community is
carried by an individual snip so it's
the fractional modularity normalized by
what we'd expect within a community so
what we did was we calculated core
scores for all the snips in the network
and we asked do these core scores in
some way reflect known biology so to
address that question we looked at 274
disease associated snips from the NH IG
NHGRI gos catalog and what we found was
that the core scores for these snips are
far higher than one would expect by
chance right so these snips aren't
randomly distributed through the network
if we look at the distribution of the
core scores the core scores for the
disease associated snips universally are
off the charts okay so what this tells
us is that disease associated genetic
variants tend to concentrate at the
center at the core of their functional
communities we then went back and asked
about jiwa snips that had been
discovered within COPD so Michael Chow
and some of his colleagues published a
meta-analysis of key wasps data in COPD
they identified 34g was--it's
that were associated with the disease so
what we decided to do is to take those
34 hits and actually look at their core
scores when we did what we found was
that the jiwa score scores were not
slightly elevated in fact when we looked
at the disease associated snips in the
appropriate tissue the core scores were
20 times higher than the average core
score in the network right so what that
really says to us is that disease
associated genetic variants sit at the
cores of their community and the reason
they sit at the core of their community
is that they are the ones
that are most likely to perturb function
they're not at the core of the network
they're at the core of their local
functional community and the reason is
that when you develop a disease you
don't develop it because the network
falls apart you die you develop a
disease because processes are disrupted
and that's exactly what this model tells
us so we look at the model we see the
global hubs in the network aren't us
hits but instead the network's groups
group snips and genes together into
communities and it tells us what we
should expect a family of snips regulate
a process or a function the G was snips
map to communities whose genes have
functions that make biological sense and
in fact they tend to be at the cores of
their local communities or at least
highly connected within them they're the
ones most likely to disrupt those
functions so the individual structure of
the network is informative in ways that
individual snips or each utl
associations are not so we actually
published this in the summer of 2016 and
I started by telling you we're excited
about the gtex data so the question we
asked in gtex was if we look across more
than one tissue and we look in
individuals who don't have a particular
disease what do we find so we wanted to
look at how general what we discovered
was in the COPD GTL analysis so I
mentioned earlier the gtex has a lot of
data there about 600 individuals in the
release we worked with that had been
genotyped we had gene expression data
from 50 different sites around the body
about 9400 expression profiles we
downloaded all this data from DB gap
under an approved analysis protocol we
took those data and after normalizing
the data across all the different
tissues we ran a fairly standard each
utl analysis similar to the method that
I described
COPD so we mimic that analysis and we
began to ask how similar is what we find
in all these different tissues the first
thing we found was that in the 13
different tissues for which we had
enough data to do an analysis and our
threshold was about 200 samples we look
at only those 13 tissues where we had
200 samples what we discovered in this
case I'm showing a heart left ventricle
what we discovered was the network was
organized into the same type of highly
modular communities we had seen in COPD
and in fact we saw that in each and
every one of the tissues so the
modularity range is between about 0.7
and whole blood to a little over 0.9 and
in fact if you look in the panel in
purple on the right what you'll see is
that there on the guess is on the left
if you look at the panel on the left
what you'll see is that each one of
these communities in fact most of the
communities are very highly modular so
we see the same basic structure we had
seen when we looked at COPD so one of
the questions people have asked us is
whether or not this structure is
actually simply driven by co-expression
and 4g texts we had a really interesting
opportunity because we see the structure
now for us 13 tissues so what we did was
we looked at the correlation and gene
expression within individual communities
and if you look at the plot here on the
right hand side what you'll see is the
distribution of pairwise correlation
coefficients in each one of the
communities and we look carefully what
you see is that almost all of them for
the communities are close to zero
they're centered around zero the
communities themselves even though you
might think that snips are gathering
co-expressed genes together correlated
genes they're not actually linked in
those communities by correlation they're
linked by genetic associations between
the snips and the expression levels of
individual genes and in fact when we
look at those snips
no matter how we look at them we don't
see that they bring together only genes
whose expression levels are highly
correlated the next thing we asked was
are the communities functionally
enriched across multiple tissues and it
turns out the answer is yes what's
really interesting is we see a lot of
communities that are functionally
enriched for functions that are shared
across many many different tissues but
we also see tissue specific functional
communities so if we take this model and
zoom in if you look at the little sort
of snake plot on on the right hand side
what you'll see is that we have
functional communities that map together
to many of the different tissues that we
wanted to explore and try to understand
so the communities are shared but
they're actually some communities that
are unique and distinctive in individual
tissues and when I say the communities
are shared they're not shared perfectly
what I mean is that the functional
associations the groups of genes
together are largely shared but not
exactly so you see a lot of shared
functionality and core processes but we
actually see distinctive communities
arise in individual tissue so it's not
quite what we would have expected but
it's actually again probably should have
expected that a lot of G wasps or a lot
of eqtl associations are common but
they're actually associations that are
unique and that by looking at the
networks you can start to tease out what
the differences are between them because
the unique eqtls don't operate in
isolation they bring other things in
other snips and gene in genes in with
them to form new regulatory communities
and that's essentially exactly what we
found so this is just an example for
heart left ventricle community number 86
the circus plot is actually showing that
what we're doing is we're bringing in
snips and genes from all over the genome
and associated them together and then
the little bubble plot is showing
enrichment for different biological
functions really addressing this
question of how the individual networks
or the individual communities within
networks are enriched for in this case
tissue specific biological functions so
the networks and their structure are
doing more or less what we might have
expected if we think about how complex
diseases and complex phenotypes work we
don't have a single variant affecting a
single trait or a single gene we have
families of variants that affect
families of genes and as genes turn on
and off across tissues the association's
in those families actually adjusts
depending on what genes are being
expressed and what variants are
available to begin to regulate them so
this is actually an interesting finding
and I'll come back to that in a little
bit the other thing of course we wanted
to know was is the other lesson we
learned from looking at COPD generalized
to these multi tissue networks and the
answer is yes jiya snips are course but
not hubs so we find the gene wash it's
not at the center of the global network
but at the center of the local community
and in fact in each one of the 38:13
tissues we looked at the jiwa score
scores are substantially higher than the
course cores for all of the other snips
in the network so we're learning the
same lesson for multiple tissues that we
saw in a single tissue and in fact when
we look at those degree distributions
what we see is time and again the the
representation of G was--it's is
over-represented up to about degree 10
and then completely disappears at high
degree so it's those course snips the
things at the center of their local
communities that are associated with
disease that we can identify through G
wasps gy sniffs perturb
functions and functional communities the
other thing that was interesting that we
really wanted to ask ourselves was if we
look at the snips at different locations
around our eqtl networks and partition
them based on where those snips are
located are there differences in the
regulatory potential and again when we
ask that question the answer was yes in
fact what we discovered is that course
snips are far more likely based on a
regular DB analysis those core snips are
far more likely to have elevated
regulatory potential relative to all of
the other snips in the network so the
likelihood of being disease-associated
is tied to your core score and your
regulatory potential is tied to your
core score there's really a common theme
that's starting to emerge but I think
even more interesting than this is what
happens with tissue specificity and this
was something this is a question we were
only able to begin to ask once we had 13
different tissues because in a single
tissue what we see are all the
communities in that tissue but we don't
know what's unique and distinctive about
each tissue so we looked in each one of
these 13 tissues actually we we ended up
focusing on 8 and the reason we focused
on 8 was the roadmap epigenomics project
had mapped chromatin state and only
eight of the tissues that we profiled in
this gtex analysis so we looked at those
eight tissues we look at the tissue
specific communities in those eqtl
networks and we asked ourselves of those
communities what can we learn about the
snips and their chromatin state and what
was really interesting was when we
compared the local hubs to the global
hubs we saw striking differences well
looking tissue-specific communities in
each of these eight tissues what we saw
was enrichment for snips
that are in tissue specific active
chromatin and when we compare that the
global hubs what we found was the global
hubs were basically enriched for
non-genic enhancer elements things away
from the genes that enhance expression
but don't regulate it so now by
combining these eqtl networks with data
from the roadmap epigenomics project
what emerges is an explanation for the
structure that we see in the eqtl
networks that in these networks we see
tissue specific communities those
communities are associated with tissue
specific expression of genes right those
communities are carrying out functions
that are unique to that tissue and in
those communities what we see is that
the snips at their center tend to be an
active chromatin that's accessible in
those specific tissues the structure of
the network is influenced by tissue
availability of steps based on chromatin
structure those chromatin structures
reorganize the network to create
regulatory modules that are specific to
that tissue and associated with tissue
specific epigenetic factors so you can
look at these oops I went backwards you
can begin to look at these in detail and
what we found were many many examples of
snips at the course of their communities
in these tissue specific communities
that map to regulatory areas in which
there's open chromatin so for us this is
really exciting because we move
from a kind of correlative and
descriptive analysis to one in which the
model actually has some explanatory
power and I think even when we didn't
copd has some explanatory power but now
by looking at the chromatin state of the
snips we're actually able to move
towards understanding mechanism and this
was something we could only have
discovered by looking at these network
structures so if you're interested I
mentioned earlier that we had published
this paper on a method called Condor in
fact we've done an analysis of these
eqtls across multiple tissues in my
group we really want to see our work
available and used so almost everything
we do we post on bio archive so in fact
is a paper describing this to some bio
archive and I thought I had it here I'll
show it to you in the next slide but
I'll tell you why I think this method
isn't wrong but first I just want to go
back and say the method we published
about a year ago is available it's
published in PLoS computational biology
we have software available that you can
download and run
it's a bioconductor package called
Condor you're more than welcome to take
that and run it on your own data to
replicate what we've done or to mirror
what we've done but I want to tell you
why I think this isn't wrong and I won't
claim it's right but I really do think
it has a lot of explanatory power
first the snips that are global hubs are
not gos hits the snips and genes group
into communities that make sense a
family of sniffs regulate a function or
a process q ah sniffs map the functional
families that make sense the course
snips are far more likely to be diseased
snips and the structure of the network
is informative while individual genes
snip associations may not be but I think
the gtex data goes beyond what we
learned from our starting point and that
is that while there are many cysts nips
and sniff each sip eqtl that are shared
across multiple tissues there are
actually many eqtl communities that are
distinct
in unique to individual tissues so
almost things most of the systems are
shared there are some unique ones and
the unique trance nips and what those do
is they organize the network differently
but in meaningful ways in each
individual tissue creating tissue
specific functional communities when we
look at these what we see is these
tissue specific functional communities
are enriched for snips that come from
tissue specific active chromatin and so
irrespective of tissue what we have is a
network that's modular in which
functionally enriched communities have
course snips that are likely to be
disease-associated high so I think this
goes a really long way to taking kind of
the vagaries of analyzing gee wass data
and the snips we find in a functional
context and it actually places it into a
context where we can think about looking
at those snips and understanding what
they do in understanding their potential
regulatory potential beyond that we
started to think about how we might go
back and actually validate these snips
in interesting ways and and one idea we
had that we're looking to try to try in
the future is to take snips at the core
of the network and rather than doing
jiwa studies with all the snips taking
the upper quartile of course cores and
maybe the things that are at the hubs
but maybe not since they don't seem to
be a gos associated but to take snips
based on their centrality in the network
and to use those to do genome-wide
Association studies where we use
function based on the EQ tiel's to beat
down some of the multiple testing
problems that we worry about so is this
true
well I turn back to one of my idols
Stephen Colbert and the word from his a
program on Comedy Central and it is very
first show you use a phrase I really
like truthiness when you feel it in your
but you know it must be right and while
I can't prove every individual
association we can't get down in the
level of the weeds but in fact when we
look at that mid-level structure that
structure is more informative about the
way in which snips operate to influence
phenotype then virtually any other model
I've looked at it feels right in a lot
of ways so I hope you find this kind of
truth e if you're interested in more I
mentioned we published a number of
papers doing analysis of gtex that
includes a pipeline for doing multi
tissue sparsa where gene expression
normalization a paper that describes our
analysis of these eqtls another paper
that looks at the difference between
cell lines and the primary tissues from
which they were derived a fourth paper
that looks at sexual dimorphism across i
think 32 tissues another paper that
looks at gene regulatory networks and
gene expression in tissue specific
manner and then another paper that i'm
very excited about that i would have
loved to talk to today if i had more
time some work really led by Joe berry
to look at individual imaging phenotypes
from histological slides that gtex had
made available to look at parameters in
those images and to associate them with
genetic variants as an example we did
this in thyroid and we looked at
Hashimoto's syndrome a disease
associated with invasion of lymphocytes
and hypothyroidism so when we look at
the imaging features what we actually
find are genetic variants that are
associated with those imaging features
and predictive of disease so I invite
you to take a look to make it easy we
actually put together some gtex eqtls so
they're all tiny URLs and they're gtex 0
to GTECH 6 but if you just go to bio
five and search for my last name
Quackenbush you'll find all these papers
so I open with a quote I'm actually
going to close with two these are quotes
I really like the first is from the
science fiction author William Gibson
the future is here it's just not widely
distributed yet so hopefully now through
this conference is distributed through
10,000 or more people and one of my
favorite quotes from Enrico Fermi I'm a
physicist by training firm you as a
physicist of course and one of the
quotes from firming that I really like
is before I came here I was confused
about this subject after listening to
your lecture I am still confused at a
higher level so the last thing I want to
do is just close by recognizing the
really talented group of people I worked
with at dana-farber I have a group of
postdocs and students Joe Barry Joie
Chen Sheila Gaynor Marika Kuchar Camilla
Lopez Ramos mega Patti Joe Paulson John
Platt akin Dan schlock we worked very
closely with a colleague and former
postdoc at Brigham and Women's Kimberly
glass another faculty colleague there
Don de Mayo
and one of them can be postdocs Abby saw
noe and last but not least Nicole
Trotman has been a great support for us
we have funding for a lot of
organizations so I've been seeing
questions pop up I have a few more
minutes I'm going to lean forward bring
up the questions and just see if I can
answer some of these before well before
we get too lost so let's see if I can
get them up okay crew up wrong one
nothing is ever as easy as it looks
there we go
all right so I'm going to have time for
a few questions but the first you
mentioned tissue specificity how many of
the genes are tissue specific uh so
that's actually a very good question and
I mentioned we we have a paper on the
bio archive that's under review now
looking at
what we mean by tissue specificity it
was very interesting when we started
doing normalization we discovered that
there was really only a small core of
genes but that a lot of genes appeared
to be specific to individual tissues
well we actually Dovan to this and began
to look carefully what we discovered was
the tissue specificity in many ways was
a misnomer that while we tend to think
of tissue specific genes they're really
more tissue limited in their range that
they're usually small numbers of tissues
that will express tissue specific gene
not the entire repertoire but a small
number and so we see a limited range in
tissue expression not specificity on the
other hand we look at these eqtl
networks what we find is that there are
range limited genes that are expressed
and that those map to communities with
functions that really help us understand
the function of the tissue and what the
tissue is doing and when we look at the
the snips as I mentioned earlier those
snips are in regions that have been
active annotated as being active
chromatin in individual tissues so we're
not yet sure about how that limited
range tissue expression correlates
exactly with open chromatin but it's one
of the questions we really want to try
to explore and again I really want to
compliment the people responsible for
gtex because it's given us an amazing
playground to begin to ask fundamental
questions about gene regulation and the
processes associated with it so it's
another question you started by talking
about the G wasps problem how would this
solve that problem well I think it does
two things first what this analysis
allows us to do is to go back in and to
look at snips that been identified
through G wasps and map them to
functions or functional groups the other
thing it allows us to do
and I alluded to this earlier if it
gives us the opportunity to look at
snips and based on predictions we make
from the network models map them forward
to jiwa studies so we could take all the
snips rank them by Corps score take the
upper quartile and rerun G was one of
the things we'd love to do maybe before
going down that road is actually to look
at independent studies where we have
this kind of data to really understand
how replicas how replicable these
networks in their communities are across
multiple tissues that's been hard to do
I didn't get a chance to tell you about
some analysis today that we're working
on
but we've been applying these methods to
look at chronic obstructive pulmonary
disease and other datasets the first one
I told you about was in lung tissue we
actually have data from two independent
studies and blood and as we've been
looking at whole blood and G Watson
whole blood each ETL analysis and whole
blood in COPD what we're seeing is that
just like when we compared multiple
communities across tissues when we look
across studies there's a great deal of
homogeneity in terms of the functions
that are represented and the structure
of the overall networks so they don't
replicate perfectly but they actually
tell a very coherent story and I think
at the end of the day that explanatory
power is one of the the most interesting
questions we have to address so sorry my
calendar just came up telling me I'm
almost done so another question how
significant are changes in the eqtl
network topology and I decided to ask
that answer that one because this is
similar to it's related to the question
I just discussed right how we compare
communities between networks and this is
actually a really interesting open
statistical problem there lots of
methods have been developed to look at
communities between
Network's some of them just look at
differences between the networks and
then compare back and forth some of them
compare to communities to a background
of random networks we've actually been
developing methods and this has really
worked at mega Patty's been doing
looking at comparisons of one network in
the context of the background of another
network but how precisely to do that has
been a challenge meg has actually
developed an idea around message passing
that looks to be statistically sound and
robust but I will say that this is still
an open question so I tend to speak of
it a little bit qualitatively we have
lots of metrics that tell us the
communities are very similar in terms of
shared snips shared genes shared
structures but now I can actually give
you a p-value yet because as I said
that's still an open question in network
biology so someone asked are the
software and data available if you go
and look at any of the papers in bio
archive they're links in each paper to
the underlying software my group and I
are really committed to reproducible
research so every paper we publish has
software and has the at least an
Associated vignette so you can run the
analysis and try to reproduce it so we
really try to describe what we do the
caveat of course is that the eqtl data
the the GOS data is protected data
that's available though through DB gap
the process of applying for access to
that data is easy and if you download
both the data and the gene expression
data what you'll discover is that you
have to normalize the data we have a
paper on a method we call yarn for doing
that normalization that will tell you
how to reproduce that kind of multi
tissue normalization I will caution you
that if you want to reap reproduce or
replicate the eqtl analysis the data the
gene expression data that's available on
the gtex portal is slightly different
than the data that's available from
dbgap
so just recognize that if you want to
that's data you probably want to be
careful when we started this analysis we
went back to DB gap to have access to
all the primary data so there's another
questions kind of related to that how
similar are the RR analysis how similar
is our analysis to the analysis from
gtex we'll look at the eqtls as I
mentioned earlier a lot of the cysts are
shared it's about 80% so there are some
differences that we see between our snip
calls and their snip calls we can
compare our trans calls to theirs
because they didn't publish any but the
cysts calls are highly highly correlated
and I can't comment on the network
structure because as I mentioned earlier
we don't have those cysts myths we don't
have G text as Knapp trance nips I
wanted to show you a website where we've
put up that has the system calls
unfortunately it's still on a pilot
server it's not on a production server
yet so I can't give you the URL but if
you come back and look for our paper
which we hope will be published soon
there'll be a link to that and we may
try to push it out through through the
paper and bio archive I probably only
have time for one or two more questions
one quick question
you only do 13 tissues gtex has data on
almost 50 sites why didn't you do more
the answer that question is simple we
only looked at tissues where we had more
than 200 samples so we did the analysis
for more but we really wanted to publish
in tissues where you had a high degree
of confidence so those are the 13 you
saw and the other question do you have
to do anything special with the data to
do the EEG analysis across tissue
across multiple tissues again what we
really did was built what I think is a
pretty robust quality control pipeline
and one of the things we did was that
multi tissue normalization from the RNA
seek data one of the things I
looking into right now is whether we can
deposit that normalized RNA seek data
back into either DB gap or hopefully
since it's normalized we just have count
data into geo one of the other things
we're very interested in doing is making
the networks that we've developed
available it turns out there's no
repository today that will accept those
but we're looking into different options
to try to do that so I think I've more
than exhausted my time but I want to
thank you for spending time with me
today for sitting and listening to me
talk about some of the work we've done I
hope you're as excited about it as we
are and I'm sorry to get to answer
everyone's questions but if you look at
the very last slide if it's still up I
have to go back there we go it's still
there if you look at the very last slide
in the upper right hand corner is my
email address my name is John
Quackenbush if you google me I'm pretty
easy to find but if you have open
questions who want to drop me a note I'm
more than happy to answer them so again
thank you very much thank you to the lab
roots people for organizing what I think
is really an exciting conference and I'm
looking forward to the next couple days
and I'm just very grateful to be a part
of it so thank you and enjoy the rest of
the conference and the rest of your day